Canada is not only known for great
bagels and really great montreal-style
smoked meat I know my all of my Canada
references are so Quebec centric people
will be mad at me in the audience our
friendly neighbors to the north are
closer to marijuana legalization the
house in Canada has approved bill c-45
in the House of Commons the vote was 200
to 82 next it goes to the Senate and
there is talk that some conservative
senators may not let this happen or at
least not let it happen as quickly as
the house in Canada wants it to happen
the initial plan was for legalization by
July of 2018 which at this point is
seven eight months away basically eight
eight eight and a half months away the
longer that this takes the more
difficult it will be for legal marijuana
to be implemented by next summer in
Canada and the fascinating thing is that
Canadian conservative senators are not
necessarily opposed period they just
seem to feel or many of them feel that
July of 2018 is just too soon and
they're proposing maybe July of 2019
instead I'm actually really jealous of
Canada not because they're headed to
legal pot specifically I don't smoke pot
as people know I'm jealous because
Canadian government seems to be
functioning in a way that's somewhat
closer to rationality and common sense
than what we have in the United States
that's what actually is making me
jealous of Canada here and how this is
going to work with American law will
also be interesting to see we know that
Americans have been traveling to Canada
for decades between ages 18 and 21
because of the 18 year old drinking age
there this is going to be a whole new
thing the amount of tax revenue that
this is expected to produce is exciting
even to the Conservatives in the
Canadian Senate and I can only assume
that customs check at the US border and
at airports for people coming back from
Canada are going to be slightly more
intense at least as long as the United
States continues to have a schedule one
level illegality of marijuana
at the federal level which is shameful
we've been talking about that for years
it's really easy to just write this off
as okay
Canada will make some money off of pot
and the US won't and it will impact
incarceration a little bit in Canada but
that'll be it
that is very wrong one of the biggest
impediments to more research on medical
marijuana in the United States is that
it is a Schedule one drug and illegal
federally it is very difficult to do
real research when that is the case and
I know research is done on medical uses
of cannabis but a fraction of what could
potentially be done and this is going to
give Canada the legalization of
marijuana in Canada going to give the
country the possibility at least of
making huge leaps and bounds in terms of
innovation and scientific research on
marijuana and again it's going to leave
the United States and the dust and we've
been talking about this for a while Pat
Trump pulls out of the Paris climate
agreement the United States subsidizes
oil Trump wants to resuscitate the coal
industry and embarrassing dying industry
to try to resuscitate meanwhile China
and India are crushing it on alternative
energy and renewables and the u.s. is
just left in the dust right now if you
want to talk to the experts on pollution
reduction and alternative energy etc you
go to China or India not the United
States it's gonna be the same thing with
the marijuana research why would you
come to the US to talk about the
research to get advice about the
research to try to do the research when
it's illegal federally you go to Canada
or somewhere else yeah especially
because the current Attorney General the
United States jeff Sessions oh yeah said
that good people don't smoke marijuana
don't go to Canada is that it's at sort
of this cultural level it's not even
we've got the legal part but then it's
the cultural stuff that Pat is pointing
out where what was that line from Jeff
Sessions the Attorney General he didn't
used to think that negatively about the
KKK until he found out that they some of
them smoked pot right anything like that
it's it's beyond just the legal
framework in order to change the legal
framework in any significant way we're
really going to need to change the
cultural framework
and the cultural framework at least when
you look at the Justice Department in
the Attorney General it is not looking
good so what else can we say other than
congratulations to Canada I mean
Canadians are already considered so
laid-back and nice stereotypically yeah
don't you think this will just further
that oh yeah they're gonna get even more
mellowed out on the cannabis yeah for
sure I think I think you're absolutely
right about that the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership